[Música]
bienvenidos a este especial de noticias
en france 24 2020 se consolidó como un
año de avances científicos sin
precedentes surgidos para dar respuesta
a la pandemia de coronavirus en tan solo
meses ya hay vacunas como la de facer
bayón tech o la de modernas aprobadas en
varios países y algunos estados han
iniciado campañas masivas de vacunación
pero con el avance científico ha llegado
también un panorama de desigualdades
entre los países el llamado primer mundo
ha asegurado cientos de millones de
dosis para iniciar la inoculación de sus
ciudadanos desde ahora mientras para el
resto del planeta las perspectivas de
vacunación masiva son más instantes para
analizar los avances y retos en materia
de inmunización frente al hobbit 19 nos
acompaña el doctor javier tello médico
cirujano y analista en políticas de
salud pero antes veamos el siguiente
informe que nos prepara nuestra
periodista natalia plazas
un año de avances sin precedentes en la
carrera por el antídoto contra el
coronavirus aunque las vacunas suelen
necesitar años o décadas de
investigación en 2020 la ciencia ha dado
pasos de gigante para producir un
antídoto contra el hobbit 19 la carrera
inició en enero cuando se descifró el
genoma del virus sars coptos de usted
este paso hace posible que avancen
muchas cosas que se han ahora
existen 18 posibles vacunas en etapas
finales de pruebas en humanos 163 en
ensayos clínicos y otras 85 en ensayos
preclínicos una de las más avanzadas es
la de la multinacional facer y la
farmacéutica variante -que la vacuna ya
ha sido aprobada en nueve países entre
los cuales reino unido eeuu canadá chile
y ecuador en todos estos con una
licencia de emergencia por otro lado en
china cuatro vacunas desarrolladas en el
país han sido aprobadas y en rúsia un
antídoto nacional recibió el aval de
moscú entretanto varios países han
iniciado ya sus planes de vacunación
rusia fue el primero en empezar una
inmunización para el personal médico
dores sociales y profesores días después
reino unido dio inicio a su primera
campaña de inmunización con la vacuna de
facer y al poco tiempo estados unidos
canadá e israel siguieron sus pasos
china por su parte ha inmunizado a un
millón de ciudadanos y preparan dosis a
gran escala para vacunar a toda su
población y a la de países que no son
ricos sin embargo a pesar de los grandes
avances científicos en este 2020 la
amplia brecha entre los países para
comprar las vacunas hace que la
inmunización global contra el cob y 19
se vislumbre aún lejana
y como les decíamos al inicio del
programa nos acompaña el doctor xavier
tello cirujano y experto en políticas de
salud para analizar los principales
retos en materia de distribución de
estas vacunas doctor de ello gracias por
estar con nosotros en france 24 con
varias vacunas distribuyéndose y otras
más en camino de aprobación cuáles son
los principales retos para lograr esta
inmunización colectiva a nivel global
bueno muchas gracias
los retos principales son en el proceso
mismo de la vacunación el fabricar
vacunas aparentemente es algo que ya
empezamos a hacer bien es como lo
estaban ustedes mencionando realmente un
logro de la ciencia moderna
ahora el reto grande es un reto
logístico hay que entender que en el
mundo se tienen que vacunar
aproximadamente a cinco mil millones de
personas adultas y esto no es una tarea
fácil si bien los países que tienen más
dinero o que tienen realmente programas
en los que pueden auxiliar se tanto de
la iniciativa privada o de operadores
logísticos importantes van a poder
hacerlo más fácil hay que considerar que
tenemos países de nivel medio y países
muy pobres los cuales han venido
tradicionalmente vacunándose con el
auxilio de otros países incluso con el
auxilio de la unicef
por ejemplo en etapas normales para
programas de vacunación infantil para
vacunar ahora obligatoriamente a todos
los adultos mayores de 16 años y entre
ellos muchos que van a requerir dos
dosis esta es una labor enorme que
además necesita recursos humanos y
recursos materiales tiempos realmente
una ingeniería
esos muy avanzadas doctor antes de
continuar con nuestra conversación le
invito a que veamos un panorama de cómo
los países ricos han acaparado más del
51 por ciento de estas primeras dosis de
las vacunas contra el cob y 19 algunas
de las principales potencias se han
hecho con dosis suficientes para
inmunizar varias veces a sus poblaciones
incluso a pesar de que la mayoría de las
vacunas necesitan dos dosis para lograr
la inmunización la unión europea que
cuenta con 446 millones de habitantes
aproximadamente ha ordenado mil 485
millones de dosis a diferentes
farmacéuticas asimismo lo han hecho eeuu
que con 328 millones de ciudadanos
cuenta ya con 900 millones de dosis de
distintos fármacos japón es otro de los
países que más vacunas ha reservado
respecto a su población de 126 punto 5
millones para la cual ha ordenado ya 540
millones de dosis en unido por su parte
ha reservado 357 millones de dosis
66 puntos 6 millones de ciudadanos
destaca también en canadá que para sus
38 millones de habitantes tiene ya
superados los 270 millones de dosis
y como consecuencia de este
acaparamiento de las vacunas por parte
de las principales potencias los países
de escasos recursos enfrentan un amplio
reto para adquirir los antídotos la
mayoría de estas naciones están
adscritas a la alianza kóvacs cuyo
objetivo es asegurar el acceso justo a
estas vacunas la alianza kóvacs fue
creada con los objetivos de llegar a los
91 países más pobres de áfrica asia y
américa latina también vacunar al 20 por
ciento de su población más vulnerable
suministrar 2000 millones de dosis en el
año 2021 iniciar además la disolución en
el primer trimestre 2021 y reunir 65
millones de dosis en el primer trimestre
del próximo año
doctor viendo todo este panorama quiero
volver entonces con usted y qué tan
factible es que el fondo kóvacs pueda
cumplir con su promesa de inmunizar al
20% de la población más vulnerable del
mundo
es un reto muy grande por varios
factores el primero es que cuando se
hicieron estos postulados hace unos
meses se pensaba que posiblemente podría
fluir mucho más la fabricación y
aprobación de vacunas y hay que entender
que en este momento solamente son pocas
las vacunas que han obtenido registros
de uso sanitario en el mundo todavía
hasta hace unas semanas me kóvacs no
sabía si realmente iba a poder poder
cumplir perdón con los tiempos el no
cumplir con los tiempos va de la mano
con el abasto que pueden tener para este
20% de la población ese es el primer
punto 2 yo creo que el esfuerzo es muy
loable y que es un gran esfuerzo a nivel
internacional pero el cubrir al 20 por
ciento de la población de cualquier
manera es muy poco seguimos todavía
pensando cómo van a hacer los países de
ingreso medio bajo y los países pobres
sobre todo que eran los que estaban
pendientes de que tuviéramos esta
como sea este inventario de vacunas a su
disposición como lo van a lograr y aquí
hay que entender que estos países ricos
que han tenido digamos un inventario más
grande asegurado lo han hecho para tener
una seguridad mientras no existan las
vacunas aprobadas y certeza de la fecha
de entrega ellos siguen estando igual
que el resto de la población en espera
de tener una certeza es solamente hasta
que puedan tenerlas
disponibles hasta que se abran realmente
cuántas iban a utilizar doctor hablemos
de américa latina' primero pero primero
veamos cómo está el panorama en nuestra
región buena parte de los países se han
adherido al fondo kóvacs y algunos
también han firmado acuerdos con
farmacéuticas privadas entre los países
que han comprado vacunas el fondo kóvacs
se encuentra en colombia uruguay
paraguay y guatemala por su parte
honduras el salvador y bolivia se
beneficiarán de las donaciones del fondo
entretanto son varios los países que han
firmado acuerdos unilaterales con las
farmacéuticas entre
esto se encuentra brasil que ha
asegurado 93.4 millones de dosis de la
vacuna negociadas con la farmacéutica
fase de sinovac también astrazéneca
méxico por su parte ha firmado convenios
con astrazéneca facer y el centro ruso
gamal ella y la empresa china cancino
biologics por un total de 178 millones
de dosis de esta vacuna entre tanto
chile ha negociado con astrazéneca
pzifer sinovac y actualmente tiene
ordenadas 84 millones de dosis de estas
farmacéuticas y por su parte colombia ha
asegurado 20 millones de dosis de diez
de la vacuna de astrazéneca y la
universidad de oxford y diez de la
farmacéutica by un tec pero también ha
negociado 10 millones de dosis de esta
vacuna de facer y venezuela- otros 10
millones de vacunas rusas producidas por
el centro de investigación gamma gamal
ella como ya lo habíamos venido diciendo
doctor le pregunta entonces en qué
situación se encuentra américa latina
respecto a la distribución de ésta
de vacunas
bueno es una situación bastante peculiar
y muy variable por un lado algunos
países tienen en el caso de méxico
solamente para precisar un esquema mixto
le habían comprado o habían firmado
algunas con kóvacs en este esquema de
precios especiales en donde repito nada
más rápidamente hay que esperar a que
estén listas las vacunas y sin embargo
todos los el resto de las compras
específicas que se están haciendo
dependen de cuando se obtenga la
disponibilidad en el orden de producción
otra vez los inventarios que salen
primero son para los países que ya
pagaron full price ahora específicamente
el panorama que tiene américa latina es
el de un reto muy grande insisto a nivel
logístico aunque tuvieran en este
momento las vacunas ya listas o las
tuvieran los inventarios en sus países
lo que sigue son los procesos de
vacunación sabemos que algunas de estas
vacunas perdón requieren de tecnologías
especiales de refrigeración como es el
caso de uno de facer y de baión tech y
que otras tienen pueden seguir lo que es
una cadena sería norma
como las que han utilizado siempre las
vacunas de cualquier manera el reto es
un número uno de recursos humanos cuánta
gente va a lograr vacunar a estas
personas no los insumos los consumibles
el combustible la logística los tiempos
estamos hablando de cientos de miles de
personas que deberían ser vacunados de
manera diaria en estos países y eso es
complicado doctor se nos acaba el tiempo
tengo que despedir gracias por estar con
nosotros el doctor javier tello médico
cirujano y analista en políticas de
salud gracias por estar con nosotros y
ustedes también gracias por siempre
acompañarnos aquí en nuestra pantalla
esto de france24 continúen con nosotros
[Música]